what song
that you've come out with is your
favorite
horse
[Music]
yeah selena gomez is just like us and
jams out to her own songs oh yeah oh my
goodness yeah it's amazing
the singer made the reveal during a
celebration for her beauty brand's
newest drop where she played a
rapid-fire q and a game with tick-tock
star michaela noguera oh liz you'd love
me of course
[Music]
to love me marked the beginning of
selena's long-awaited musical comeback
in 2019 the lead single off her 2020
album rare you promised the world and i
fell for it
selena's since dropped a
spanish-language episode
[Music]
but selenators have been waiting for
some new pop tunes oh my gosh
but the good news they're on the way yes
i'm actually working on it right now
it's just been a little hectic with this
but i'm i am in the studio i'm excited
selena confirmed to et she's back in the
studio at the premiere for season two of
her show only murders in the building
which has been keeping her busy as of
late evidence keeps showing up in our
apartments who's ever doing this
is toying with us this ends the
investigation into a whole new direction
but now that the show's all shot it's
time for selena's career to get back in
the music direction here's what we know
about her next era i am in
la working on my album now i am open to
a tour a thousand percent but i
obviously have obligations and things
that i want to do so when the time's
right it's not the top of my priority
list selena dropped those nuggets on a
deadline podcast back in may we don't
know when we'll get ears on new tunes or
eyes on selena back on stage but we do
know it'll be before the end of the year
should we expect anything else from rare
beauty this year
well maybe
then maybe
oh
no way
we're holding you to it selena and in
the meantime we'll be listening to our
favorite song on repeat
[Music]
this dancer was killing me softly
i needed to hate you to love me
[Music]
i needed to lose you to love me